hello everyone and welcome back to the
air things masters uh while rajabov and
lebanon are
brawling it out uh to see who will win
uh first prize
dubois and maxine vashay lagrave has to
settle uh who will
get third place and it's been very hard
choosing which game to show as all four
games between these two fine gentlemen
ended
uh with uh uh with a decisive result
and this is game four i decided to show
so interestingly
first dooba won the two games and then
the third game ended
by maxime uh winning one of the games uh
but it was
uh again dubo attacking in third game so
it's like you already won two games you
just need a draw but no dude
went for a very aggressive attack and
then maxine was able to win that game
and now this is the last game maxime
needs a win to tie the match or
dubo simply needs a draw and then uh you
know he he
wins the first match so let's see what
happened here as it's quite
the game so do with the white pieces
opens with e4
we have c5 maxine goes for the sicilian
defense knight to f3
d6 and bishop to b5 the canal attack
uh we have knight to d7 and here a dub
of just castles we have a6 and now
bishop captures on d7 so this is all a
fairly standard stuff
uh and c3 now preparing the strike in
the center with the d4 we have knight to
f6 by maxine
uh attacking the pawn here and now rook
to e1 and now as the bishop has been
developed to d7 now the bishop comes to
c6 and now
there's a double attack on this pawn
here but dubo simply ignores that he
pushes d4
and it's not a new idea this is a very
uh well-known pawn sacrifice in this
line of the sicilian there are over 350
games in top tier games
uh with this exact same position so
bishop captures an e4
and now bishop to g5 white of course
will get some development in for the
price of that pawn
now already you are threatening to
remove the defender of the bishop maybe
cause some damage here
so here bishop retreating with the
bishop bishop the d5 or c6 are
the most uh played moves here but uh
maxim switches diagonals he goes bishop
to g6
and now uh it's do both to move and he
goes d5 so he wants to
uh stifle black's development for as
long as possible
and maxim says okay not a problem i'm
just gonna castle queen side so he
prepares it
queen to d7 now uh queen side castling
uh is gonna be played and now
knight b to d2 all been played before
we have queen side castle by maxime and
here there are some games in the
database where knight the c4 was played
immediately
going after that b6 check which is a
very nice royal fork
but here we have b for baidubo and this
is very interesting
as it also shows how prepared the dubo
is in these games as
knight the c4 was the only move played
in this position
however newer engines prefer b4 so do
both came very well prepared here
uh it is as of move 12 that we have a
completely new game and
obviously the strongest move um that was
available
in the position so let's see how maxime
deals with this obviously you could
capture the d5 pawn but if you go
for that then knight to c4 and now it's
a bit of a different uh position than
the previous one
again you are threatening the knight
here if the knight moves the knight to
b6 check again wins the queen so it's a
really
crazy position if maxine is not familiar
with this of course he will
not just grab the pawn so after this b4
move
uh we have uh like i said uh uh e6
instead by maxine
sorry about that could be the mailman
just a second
nope uh it's uh it's yelena uh yelena
says hello everyone
uh so e6 challenging now the pawn in the
center and
only now knight to c4 so going after
that b6 check and of course you have to
defend against this so queen to b5 by
maxine uh
and now knight f the d2 and what do you
play here well you could play a lot of
things in knight captures on d5 it seems
to be a very
a very nice possibility giving up the
rook here or you could go something like
c
captures on b4 but none of them are very
appealing for black so
this is very very very well prepared by
dobo because here maxine played e
captures on d5 and now it all just uh
you know crumbles down here we have a4
attacking maximum queen
queen to c6 and now b5 so
uh the position will about will open up
uh we have eight captures on b5 a
captures and queen capture so grabbing
that pawn
uh and here a very very tricky position
uh you have to
really know what you're doing here the
point is you have to go for that
d5 pawn and once you open up the
position here uh
then then black king will simply have no
squares available rook to a8 is always
an idea queen is coming to f3
uh this is such a such a great position
for white
problem is you have to eliminate the
knight on f6 and now after captures
uh knights the e3 goes after the pawn
and you can't really defend it if you
defend it for example like this queen f3
is coming and
then it's just uh open season
so here after queen captures on b5 we
have queen to f3 by double so it's a
similar
idea but the double prefers to do every
all of that
by sacrificing even more material so
maxime accepts the
sacrifice with punk captures on c4
bishop captures an f6
and now again uh g captures on f6 and
this is where maxim could have uh played
a little better
uh there is the line rook to d7 but
again it's such an ugly line
rooked a8 checking the c7 and now the
bishop has to move and
once the bishop moves now you play
bishop to e7 and you trade your rook for
bishop so rook captures you're going to
play bishop captures
and you're going to get this position
where duba would be up the exchange but
maxine would have
uh it would be up three pawns so it
would be
uh well definitely a trade off so
instead
after this bishop captures an f6 maxim
boldly accepts this we have g
captures and now duba gets the attack
going rook to a8 with
check king to c7 and now of course you
want to get the king here so you can
connect with this
check uh so rook captures of course king
captures
and now queen captures an f6 with check
king d7 and now
queen captures an h8 and now bishop to
e7 you have to defend the bishop and now
knight to f1 so here uh we have a knight
rook and queen against the queen and two
bishops so yeah it's going to be very
dangerous
white is up material but uh the bishop
pair is always always very dangerous
so here queen to b6 preparing a queen to
f8
uh they're trying to get that queen away
and now queen to a8
uh we have queen to a6 maxine wants to
trade queens and dubo of course declines
queen back to h8
and now b5 now dooba wants the uh maxine
wants to play b4
uh of course create a pass pawn and then
either captures or just continue pushing
the pawn
so here knight the e3 and now by
developing this
knight the way um do both did of course
he wants to bring the knight to d5
now he allows queen to c8 this was never
possible
uh to try and force a queen trait as
long as the knight was on f1 because it
would just capture the bishop with
check and then the queen falls so here
dubo doesn't really have a good
option for the queen all of these
squares are taken this is very passive
not much to do there
so here dubo has to trade queen captures
king captures and now
only one good move for white i'm sure
you'll see it as the
bishop is kind of loose here knight
captures in c4 you grab a pawn here
so of course black will not capture and
ruin his pawn structure black just
defends the bishop
so knight back to a3 attacking the pawn
and now
uh maxine finally creates a pass pawn
captures captures attacks the knight and
knight to c4
and now it's still uh um a rook and the
knight against
the bishop pair however the bishop pair
if this
is uh well if if they're set up
correctly will be fully operational
and then it's going to be really really
hard to stop that past pawn from
queening
so here we have king to d7 uh improving
the position of the king and now
f3 uh with b3 continuing to push the
past pawn
king f2 duo starts bringing the king
into the game but now
bishop bishop to f6 and now you
if you allow b2 then b1 is coming or
both of those squares are covered so
dubo needs to do something about that
he tries knight to d2 attacking the pawn
but
just b2 and here uh of course uh
you cannot allow the the pawn to be
pushed you can just play
some like bishop to c3 capture the
knight and then promote the pawn
so duboff tried knight the e4 now
attacking the bishop here
but now everything just wins for black
i'm not even going to ask you to pause
the video because i i know you guys
know what i'm talking about so you can
either maybe
play something like check and then after
the the king moves then you play d5 kick
away the knight and you again
gain control of the b1 square or you
play an even simpler line which is what
uh maxine played just bishop captures
knight and now
uh the bishop has to be recaptured you
cannot capture with the rook because the
pawn queen so you have to capture with
the pawn
but now the problem is bishop to g5 and
now
uh the the real threat of course is
bishop to c1 if you play something like
king f3 bishop to c1 just wins
uh because you no longer have control of
the b1 square
so here dubo had to play rook to b1 but
now
uh i'm i'm sure most of you know
what wins here for black but just in
case for some of the
newer members of the chess world feel
free to pause the video and
win this game for maxine while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on trapping the
rook on b1 and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's bishop to c1
and now the problem is uh that white
rook is trapped that white rook is never
leaving
and black is still up upon so that's
that's a huge problem
so double will try everything to hold
this but it's not going to be easy king
e2 just king e6 now maxine just needs to
bring the king into the game
king to d3 and now king to e5 we have g3
and now h5 at some point uh f5 or
or this will be played and then uh the
king will gain access to the lower part
of the board we have h3 now f6 and now
h4 and here uh now just f5 and now
the the white king will not be able to
hold everything so e captures on f5 king
captures
and now king to d4 now if you go
something like king to e2 to try and
keep an eye on this pawn just king e4
and now as you can see all of these
squares are covered by black so you're
just going to push that pawn down the
board and the white king will have to
stay there you're just going to go here
pick up the pawns and win the game
so it's very easy so duboff tried king
to d4 instead but it doesn't help
just king g4 now these pawns are gone
king d5 we have king captures and g3
king captures on d6 king captures on h4
and now
king to e5 but here uh maxim just played
king to g3 now the h file is free for
the pawn to be queened and it was in
this position that
daniel dubo resigned the game and uh
incredibly
maxime went from uh losing by a
two-point margin to equalizing the match
uh but it's just incredible like double
wins the first two games and then he
just
continues attacking like a madman not
just in game three that he lost he he
also just needed a draw in game four to
uh win the first part of the match but
no he continued attacking like a madman
and that's why we love dubose games so
hopefully he will continue doing that
for forever uh but yeah a good game uh
by maxine for uh getting back into the
match so they will also settle
uh uh the the question of the third
place today uh alongside
the final so we're gonna cover both of
that and hopefully we're going to have
some very nice games
uh so yeah that's uh the game i do hope
you guys enjoyed it
i'd like to thank a mystery person
another mystery person
alexander sevo nathan rieber and jeffrey
johnson for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot
i really appreciate it as usual you can
check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and i i will
see you soon continuing the coverage
of this very nice tournament checking up
on your suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day